a Texas school district is now requiring
students to provide a birth certificate
before auditioning for the Texas Boys
Choir or the singing girls of Texas
we are not permitted on a certain big
Tech video platform to articulate the
precise ideological reason for which
they are now requiring birth
certificates for boys and girls choirs
but I think you catch my drift and you
can hear more at Daily wire plus and the
RSS feed and Twitter Emerald's show and
actually actually
that particular ideology is not even the
most depressing part of this story
sad or even than recent eccentric
theorizing
is the clearly collapsing rates of
social Trust
we have observed this trend in society
for years your grandparents didn't used
to lock their doors you have security
systems and cameras filming from your
doorbell 24 7. your grandparents trusted
your parents to their children's
teachers today if you're a sane parent
what that means is you've probably
strongly considered homeschooling if not
engaged in it yourself
social trust has collapsed now to the
point that little kids need to carry
notarized government documents to sing
in chorus in school
and for good reason
our society no longer agrees on the most
basic facts of life we no longer speak
the same language with which to
communicate these Facts of Life and so
we view one another as barbarians and
sadly at least some of us are right I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show in just a
moment some lady I've never heard of
sings about how much she hates America
by rewriting the national anthem we'll
get to that and we'll get to what that
means in just a moment first though
I said that opening
that's the sort of opening that can
remain on a certain big Tech video
platform without being kicked off and
having us cast into outer Darkness where
there's Whaley and gnashing of teeth
this part can't stay on that particular
social media platform because the
biggest shocking most breaking news
story of the day of course
is that CNN
foreign
[Music]
when you want to protect yourself
it's an okay Transit and not my best
transition you got to check out
expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com Knowles profiling
surveillance and data harvesting are a
few things that you probably don't like
very much about the tech Giants what can
you actually do about it when you rely
on so many of their products well the
good news is doesn't take much for you
to take a stand for less than seven
bucks per month you can join me and
fight back against big Tech by using
expressvpn how do you think big tech
companies make all their money anyway
well by tracking your searches video
history and everything you click on and
then selling your personal data
expressvpn helps you anonymize much of
your online presence by hiding your IP
address a unique identifier that every
device has that allows big Tech to match
your activity back to you that is why
expressvpn is the only VPN that I use
and Trust on all of the devices to make
it much more difficult for them to
exploit my data for their own profits
and best part is it's so easy even I can
use it I'm a bit of a Luddite you just
click one button on your phone on your
computer on your tablet turns it on
keeps people out of your business time
to fight back go to expressvpn.com
Knowles get three extra months for free
expresvpn.com expressvpn.com Knowles to
learn more
speaking of fleeing things
if you were on YouTube and you didn't
catch what I was just talking about you
got to go to the RSS feed in Daily wire
plus and Twitter at M Knolls show to see
what segment was just cut out there but
speaking of fleeing things president
Trump appears
to be fleeing the early presidential
primary debates here is his advisor
Jason Miller going on TV explaining why
the president's probably not going to
come at the moment president Trump has
indicated that he's unlikely to
participate at least in the first two
debates he's up by 30 40 and even new
polling shows he's up by almost 50
percent in certain places it really
wouldn't make much sense for him to go
and debate right now with a bunch of
folks who are down at three four and
five percent even Rhonda Sanctus who's
the second place candidate in the race
currently is at least 20 30 or 40 points
behind and so ultimately president Trump
will make a decision as we get closer he
has not said anything definitive one way
or the other I'm not expecting him to
participate though
there you go top advisor to Trump saying
I'm not
or rather Trump is not likely to go to
the debates there's a candidate for him
in Iowa tomorrow
all the candidates are going to be there
Donald Trump is not going to be there so
there seems to be evidence he's going to
make good on this threat Trump's critics
in the Republican Party Liberal
Republicans like Chris sununu in New
Hampshire they are pouncing on Trump and
saying he looks like a wimp
former president Trump the tough guy
tough guy the guy that says he's going
to fight for American fights
we don't know for sure anything yet he's
going to wimp out that that clown that
child that coward why won't he get on
the debate stage
why would he
why would he I don't want you to shoot
the messenger here okay I am not working
for any campaign I have told you I do my
level best not to endorse in primary
campaigns I think I might be the only
conservative pundit in America right now
who is not actively working for one of
the presidential campaigns I like pretty
much all of the candidates in the field
I know a great number of them personally
and I have a great deal of respect for
for all of the ones that I know and even
for some of the ones that I don't know
so I'm just calling it like I see it
fellas and you cannot like the message
you can be angry about these political
facts on the ground but I'm just telling
you what it is
Trump has no incentive to debate right
now he has no incentive I've got the
real clear politics average of polling
Trump is up according to the RCP average
Trump is up
32.4 points
now the rscp average is a very reliable
fairly conservative average of polls
that includes morning consult Economist
you got Fox Emerson NBC Yahoo Harvard
Harris CNN the messenger Harris X poll
we've got all of them there Trump is
crushing the field
32.4 is the average Harvard Harris has
him up 45 points over the rest of the
field this is a 10 person field
it's not even close
so with a commanding lead like that that
he does not appear to be losing in fact
his lead only appears to either remain
the same or to be increasing as his most
intense and serious primary Challenger
seems to be losing ground
why on Earth would Trump get on that
stage
well because the voters have a right
they demand the right to see the
candidates debate they don't demand that
if those poll numbers start to change
then that will indicate that the voters
are demanding that but as of now the
voters seem to be extraordinarily
supportive of Trump without seeing him
debate the other candidates
well but they the voters should demand
it well maybe you think they should
demand it but they're not demanding it
right now well I just think it's the
right thing to do okay
maybe you would prefer that Trump get on
the debate stage I would prefer it in
many ways because it would give me more
content for my show and I'm sure it
would be extremely entertaining
but there is no moral imperative for
Donald Trump to engage in a primary
debate
and there is no law that says he has to
do it and there is no particular rule in
the Republican party that says he has to
do it
I'm sure the Republican Party would
prefer that he'd do it but don't forget
Trump engaged in a hostile takeover the
Republican Party Trump doesn't give a
damn with the party apparatchics want
if the other candidates want Donald
Trump to debate they have to create the
political circumstances that force him
to debate
and the way to create those political
circumstances is to knock his poll
numbers down if the other candidates
cannot knock his poll numbers down
then Trump showing up on that debate
stage presents all risk and no upside
that's how politics works
candidates
have one goal in a campaign and that is
to win the race the race right now is
not against Joe Biden the race is for
the Republican Party nomination you
might say well I just think Trump's not
going to be a good general election
candidate doesn't matter that's not what
we're asking right now well I just think
he's he looks cowardly maybe he does and
if enough voters think that he looks
cowardly for ditching the debates that
will be reflected in the polls and then
he will be forced to engage in the later
debates but right now I'm just I'm not
prescribing anything I'm not advocating
anything I'm just telling you why it is
the case that Trump
is inclined not to engage in the debate
he has very little to gain and quite a
lot to lose now on the other side of
this look at the Democratic party Joe
Biden is up 54 points on his next most
serious primary arrival RFK Jr
so this is a Kennedy albeit a somewhat
kooky one this is a mainstream Democrat
who's been in public life for a long
time Biden's up 54 points on him Trump
is not quite up 54 points but he's up a
similar amount on his nearest primary
arrival and don't forget there are three
candidates right now in the Democrat
field it's Biden
Bobby Kennedy and Marianne Williamson
who's much lower
if Biden's not going to debate which he
almost certainly is not then why would
Trump debate we might say well because
Biden is the incumbent and Trump's not
the incumbent yeah kind of kind of
we have not had a one-term president run
for a rematch in over 130 years
the last President to do it was Grover
Cleveland
it's only happened once in American
history that a president won
non-consecutive terms
so I grant you
Trump is not literally the incumbent
here
but practically speaking
for most intents and purposes Trump is
the incumbent you might say well he
shouldn't be treated that way that's
wrong that's not I'm not telling you
what should or should be whatever I'm
just explaining I am describing to you
why the circumstances in this primary
are different from the other primaries
you can like that you cannot like that
you can pull your hair out and scream to
the heavens
if you don't accept those political
realities you're going to become
increasingly frustrated as this
inevitably unusual primary unfolds
speaking of learning things
when you want to learn stuff you got to
check out Hillsdale College right now go
to hillsdale.edu Knowles are you a few
years or maybe a few decades out of
school and wondering what did I even
learn and what was the point you might
think to yourself that you don't have
the time to learn something new well if
that's you then know this you're not
alone it's not too late since 1844
Hillsdale College has been providing
education and Faith freedom and
character they've taken some of the core
classes they teach on campus and made
them available for free online for
anyone who wants to learn that is right
for free there were 39 free courses to
choose from ranging from the
Constitution the Book of Genesis free
market economics and so on they're easy
to follow they're self-paced so you can
start whenever you want in fact you can
start right now it's everything you need
all in one place with no long-term
commitment let Hillsdale College be your
guide learn when and where you want go
right now to hillsdale.edu Knowles to
enroll no cost it's easy to get started
Hills dale.edu Knowles to register
hillsdale.edu Knowles
you know you might have been one of the
tens of millions of people who watched
Netflix's hit show making a murderer if
so
you're going to love daily wire plus
this new exclusive 10-part docu-series
with Candace Owens convicting a murderer
coming this summer
whether it's exposing BLM or certain
fallacies in the healthcare industry
regarding covet Candace has never been
afraid to challenge The Narrative she
will find the truth wherever it leads
when Candace found out that key facts
may have been omitted in Netflix's
series she's set out to uncover the real
story behind the notorious Stephen Avery
case the end result is convicting a
murderer you will not want to miss it
you will also
get all of the other premium content
from DIY plus including the greatest lie
ever sold what is a woman and the
largest collection of content from Dr
Jordan B Peterson right now at
dailywire.com subscribe become a member
see the truth
finally comes out
speaking of the 2024 primary
looks like we might get a new
presidential candidate on the Democrat
side that would be Joe manchin
West Virginia Democrat Senator Joe
manchin who is probably the single most
moderate Democrat in the country
certainly at the federal level along
with Kirsten Cinema and really more than
Kirsten Cinema even
uh Joe manchin is also the most
vulnerable Senator looking at reelection
next year so you got a republican
Challenger who's way up on Joe manchin
right now
so what is Mansion doing is he
campaigning around West Virginia no he's
campaigning around New Hampshire he's
going to be at an event sponsored by a
group called No Labels No Labels is this
kind of squishy Middle Ground group
which pretends that losing political
distinctions is somehow good that's
that's the premise No Labels we should
have no Clarity in our political process
we should just all be part of the
uniparty that is is the real meaning of
their phrase but they think it sounds
nice because they think it sounds
non-partisan and not nasty and icky and
really nice and moderate and so this
would be a natural place for Joe manchin
to go and he's campaigning with them
to potentially consider a third party
presidential ticket on the ballot in all
50 states
the Republican governor of West Virginia
Jim Justice is leading mansion in a
hypothetical U.S Senate matchup in 2024
by 22 points he is absolutely destroying
Mansion right now because the people of
West Virginia are pretty conservative
but it's it's a holdover Democrat state
so you got the last remaining Blue Dog
Democrats conservative Democrats are
there Mansion has to satisfy his party
leadership he's got to satisfy his his
constituency those are increasingly
pulling in different directions they're
ripping Mansion apart and so it opens a
wide window for a republican like Jim
Justice to come in and beat Mansion so
what is manchin going to do
his only option really if he wants to
continue his political career is either
to suck up to Joe Biden to try to get an
appointment in a hypothetical second
term or to run for president himself
on a third party ticket I mentioned the
story not because I think Joe manchin's
going to be president or the Democrat
nominee or anything like that I mention
it because
it shows the point on the Republican
debates which is that
politicians
are often motivated by
raw hard circumstance
they're going to go where their
opportunity is this is true of all of us
this is true in our careers this is
sometimes during our personal lives this
is true in how we move from City to City
this is true in in impelling so much of
our action we follow opportunity and
this is especially true for National
level politicians who are extremely
ambitious men
so if you want to impel a different kind
of behavior if you
if you don't want Joe manchin to run for
president well then you've got to give
him
another option to maintain his political
career if you want Donald Trump to
engage in the first primary debates well
you need to create the political
circumstances that will force him to do
that
whether by damaging his poll numbers
changing some rules with the RNC that's
never going to work or something else
that I haven't thought of but you can't
just whine and say oh no why are
circumstances the way that they are this
is something that drives me crazy about
political pundits and specifically
conservative pundits is they just whine
all the time there's one and it's not
that they whine about things that they
can change I like the idea of targeted
and productive criticism to change
things and to improve the state of the
country that's not what I'm talking
about Trump describes that as you whine
whine whine until you win that's not
what I'm lamenting here
what I am constructively lamenting here
is the tendency among many conservatives
and specifically in the pundit class to
just
pointlessly moan about circumstances
that they are not going to change and
that are not going to change on their
own say oh no if the voters just weren't
so stupid they wouldn't nominate this
person I hate or oh no if the the
political apparatics in the senate or in
the bureaucracy would just get along
with this legislation that I really want
then the country would be better yeah
well bro if you want that to happen then
you you have to engage in politics
politics is an art
very closely tied to reality it's not
Pie in the Sky it's not some fantasy you
make up in your your own head you gotta
create the hard circumstances now
speaking of Southern politicians
turn to a politician in Alabama now this
would be Tommy tuberville a great U.S
senator who fell into some real hot
water
uh what did he say I don't know exactly
what he said but CNN's calling him
racist
hubberville just continues doubling down
on his comments originally he made these
comments weeks ago basically arguing
that white nationalists weren't
necessarily racist and he was pressed
repeatedly by our Caitlyn Collins
yesterday and then pressed repeatedly by
reporters again today here's what he
said why you continue to insist that
white nationalists are American listen
I'm totally Against Racism as Democrats
want to say that white nationalists are
racist I'm totally against that too but
that's not a democratic definition the
definition of a white nationalist well
that's true definition my definition it
is racism
the definition the definition is that
the belief that the right race is
superior race is totally out of the
question so do you believe that white
nationalists are racist yes if that's
what a race is yes thank you
and he just continues to Double Down
double down on what he's
um Senator chopperville why are you such
a terrible racist uh I'm not racism's
bad but yeah but why are you super duper
racist why are you a racist white evil
white nationalist white CIS male Baddie
Nazi Hitler bad bad
can you please answer that uh I'm not I
don't think I'm those things I don't
what
yes so uh back to you Jim yep that's
really uh you can see Senator
tubbleville there calling for pogroms
and burning crosses that's right Senator
tuberville a genocidal racist because
I don't know obviously tupperville has
the right answer here
his uh clear bemusement and
funny contempt for these stupid
questions from CNN is the right the
right answer don't ever grant them the
premise on this stuff it should go
without saying at this point but you
don't need to defend yourself no really
uh seriously my some of my best friends
are black and I I totally I disavow
everything every made-up term that you
can throw at me I'm sorry I'm sorry no
you just kind of bat it away huh yeah
racism is really bad yep really oh it's
very very bad
all that bad things are really really
bad that's so true but are you a
nationalist what does that even mean
what is white nationalism
what is it it's just a term that the
libs popularized in recent years
because they knew that there was a
nationalist and a populist
movement that was going on and they
don't like that because they're liberal
globalists and so they need to describe
that as bad they need to paint that that
nationalism is bad and in America the
way that you call something bad is to
call it racist those terms are
synonymous so when they use the term
white nationalism all it means is it's
racist nationalism which is to say bad
nationalism which is to say bad are you
bad no I'm not bad I'm not
now obviously the nation state is
far preferable to the liberal globalism
that all of these awful people are
trying to thrust upon us
but let's take the question
seriously here because I'm not a U.S
senator I don't need to bat away these
stupid reporters we have a little more
breathing room here to discuss these
things
what is even the premise of white
nationalism
that some people want America to be an
exclusively white country America has
never been an exclusively white country
the libs are wrong
when the libs pretend that
all the white people are really bad and
all the people who have done all the
really great stuff in America have been
black and Native American sometimes they
say they're Muslim they weren't Muslims
here until relatively recently but okay
fine whatever obviously the libs are
wrong about that
the people in the most conspicuous
positions of power the settlers of
America the the people who crafted much
of the country
by and large were white people
absolutely Libs want to revise that they
they got angry at the Abraham Lincoln
movie because the Abraham Lincoln movie
points out that Lincoln freed the slaves
they say you can't say that because
Lincoln's a white man the slaves had to
have freed themselves but of course they
didn't do that so okay obviously yeah
that that's crazy but then on the flip
side of it there are some people who
will say America's exclusively white
strictly white all the good stuff comes
from the white people none of the good
stuff comes from the other people and
that's wrong too
and the the person who
oddly enough had one of the more
insightful visions of this kind of thing
is Carl Jung you might have heard of
Carl Jung because Jordan Peterson talks
about him all the time Carl Jung uh Carl
Jung was a psychologist and a pretty
interesting writer I don't agree with
him on everything but he made some
interesting points and uh Carl Young
observed in America
this strange phenomenon whereby he was
walking on the streets of Buffalo and he
turned to someone he was walking with
and he said wow I didn't realize how
much Indian blood was in America I
didn't realize how much intermingling in
marriage and and birth there was with
the Indians and the guy said what are
you talking about we don't have much
intermarriage at all with the Indians
these are Irish people and German people
he said no they look Indian they've got
but it's not that their skin looked
Indian there was something about their
comportment that seemed foreign as
compared to an Irishman or as compared
to a German and that seemed a little bit
more akin to a Native American Indian
what's that about Jung observed that
there's something in the American
character that seems more similar to
what one would stereotypically consider
a black man to be like an African to be
like than say a Frenchman or an
Englishman or a German or an Irishman
even though the people exhibiting these
behaviors were white as the driven snow
what's that about
and what Young sees there is that this
is a matter of acculturation and
behavior that there are ideas that
motivate countries and cultures and his
ideas don't just come from genetics or
something like that they come from
culture and so in Germany for instance
is obsessed with
the idea capital I idea that's that's a
theme that has motivated Germany England
is obsessed with the gentleman
gentlemanliness is is a motivating
driving
Concept in England France it's glory
and in America it's greatness
and it's just different and these things
distinguish Americans from other sorts
of people and the way that culture works
is not
not deriving surely from biology or
something like that far from it that
that culture is created by this mixing
of peoples and geography and history
that has has occurred since the very
beginning of the country since the
Mayflower landed at Plymouth Harbor
I assume CNN would not understand any of
that and would not be interested in
hearing any of that but it is a reminder
as to why
the the premise of their question when
they hurl this at you and they're going
to hurl this at you all the time white
nationalism racism this isn't and that
isn't they're attacking something that
nobody really believes at all and and
they're doing it because of their
extraordinarily shallow and vindictive
views of things that that they are
projecting onto their political
opponents but the reality as always in
matters of History politics
philosophy as always the reality is much
richer and more interesting than the
white people bad white nationalism
disavowed disavow much much more
interesting what has really gone on in
our country now when you want to hire
much better people than the sort who
work at CNN you got to check out
ZipRecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles if you're
hiring you're probably dealing with
economic uncertainty and now more than
ever it is important to hire the right
people faster and more efficiently to
keep overall costs down thankfully zip
recruiter is a hiring partner focused on
you and your needs from pricing to
technology everything that zip recruiter
does is for you and what works best for
you right now you can try them for free
at ziprecruiter.com Knowles the
recruiters smart technology identifies
and matches for your job lets you invite
the candidates that you really want to
apply to your job before other
businesses can snag them I love how
straightforward it is the pricing is
straightforward you know exactly what
you pay for before posting your job so
you can still your budget with no
surprises hire the absolute best with
the help of a partner that is all about
you with zip recruiter 4 out of five
employers who post on the recruiter get
a quality candidate within one day go to
this exclusive web address to try to
recruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
Knowles kwles that is a ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter
smartest way to hire
my favorite comment yesterday is from
rewind gaming 9000 who says Knowles's
episodes keep getting shorter and
shorter it's almost like YouTube keeps
making more and more of his show against
their guidelines uh they do and they're
doing it capriciously and they're not
they're not even telling us what
violates their guidelines and so we are
called in this culture to be wise as the
wisest doves and innocent of serpents
quite the opposite why is the serpents
and innocent as doves and so I've said
I'm not going to censor myself period
Punta Basta so
my full show with my full commentary
that might violate any other number of
big Tech guidelines that's available on
the RSS feed on Spotify on Apple podcast
on daily wire plus of course you can get
that on Twitter at mnol's show
as for YouTube if they're looking for
some excuse to Nuke my channel I'm not
going to give it to them I'm going to
remain on YouTube I'm going to do my
level best to follow their guidelines
and then I'm going to redirect people
and say well if you want the content
that YouTube is censoring from this
platform then you got to go to the other
platforms here and maybe they'll try to
Nuke me anyway just because they don't
like the cut of my jib but we're not
going to give them any excuse to do that
so I don't know maybe the YouTube
episode will be 30 minutes I don't know
maybe it'll be 35 minutes 25 minutes I
don't know what it is but you'll get
that full episode daily wear Plus
Twitter and the RSS feed
speaking of American identity how do you
feel about your country we just had the
Fourth of July some people don't like
their country very much people like the
singer Jill Scott
can you see
that display
s doesn't survive
[Music]
on you colored
child
who's blood okay I think we get the
words bloody the blood built this land
and the white people are evil and the
black people did all the good stuff and
they're always pressed and okay whatever
here is the attention you ordered ma'am
here you are
do you want it here can I or give you
some attention hors d'oeuvre and some
perhaps an attention djsdf along with
your meal and entree of attention oh she
got it no one had ever heard of this
woman before and now now we've mentioned
her name
there are plenty of people who agree
with her
at least plenty of people who say that
they agree with her and
this poses an existential threat to the
Republic as we talked about at the very
top of the show today
we now need
in Texas school districts we need
children to present government-issued
notarized birth certificates to join the
school choir
because social trust has broken down so
much and common language is broken down
so much and Community has broken down so
much
and this would be another example of
this
polybius has a good observation the
ancient Greek historian of Rome who
pointed out that democracy can persist
only when there is reverence
for the gods only when there is
a serious disciplined limited behavior
only when there is respect for parents
and elders and we talk a lot about how
how democracy and republics are built
for moral and religious people only so
there's your reverence for the gods we
talk about how people need to be able to
control themselves or government's going
to come in and control them more
heavy-handedly
sure that's true we don't we don't talk
enough about respect for elders and why
you have to respect your elders
uh politically that is one is to have a
stable Society two it's to preserve the
basic unit of society the basic
political unit which is the family
uh and three because it's what connects
Society through the generations the
older generation cares for the younger
generation
the younger generation owes reverence
and respect for the older generation if
you hate your parents
you're going to hate your country
because your country was built by your
forefathers a friend of mine a very
perspicacious friend of mine I've used
that word a lot recently it keeps coming
to mind maybe because of all these
incisive visions that keep popping up a
friend said that all of liberalism can
be boiled down to F you Dad
that's that's all you need to know
forget John Locke forget John Stuart
Mill John Rawls a lot of John's among
the Liberals throw all of their books
out it doesn't matter all you need to
know about liberalism is that it boils
down to
F you dad and that's what you see that's
what this woman is yelling about here
the blood in the streets in this awful
place because all of my forebears and
forefathers were bad and I hate you Dad
and this is terrible and this is the the
liberal view of History
the past was bad the present is a crisis
the Utopia is right around the corner
but we've we've got to urgently pursue
progress and it it rips up everything on
which your Society previously had
relied
that's it if you don't if you got if you
got Daddy Issues that's not just a
personal problem that's going to bleed
over into a political problem as we see
today now speaking of insulting your
audience as this woman has
Fox stock
has been downgraded Fox News
dominant name and cable news has been
downgraded after
the viewership has continued to decline
Wells Fargo downgraded the fox
Corporation stock
is Fox news's viewership has not
rebounded since they fired Tucker Tucker
who was their biggest name and actually
the biggest name in the history of cable
news in May
ratings for Fox took a nosedive because
they kicked out Tucker
the Network dropped from a 3 million
viewer average to a 1.65 million viewer
average in the 8 PM hour it's almost 50
percent drop
and they haven't really rebounded so
Wells Fargo is deemed Fox Corporation
underweight because Fox News drives so
much of the profits of of the fox
Corporation and uh now with ecosystem
risks also elevated Wells Fargo finds
the estimate Outlook
more negative and below the street below
Wall Street okay
Fox might not be able to ride this one
out
previously
the corporate understanding of boycotts
was that boycotts usually don't matter
all that much if they do matter at all
they're going to matter from the left
because the left has the institutional
power and so if if the libs call for a
boycott
they'll probably cave at least to some
degree and then everything will be fine
if the conservatives call for a boycott
it doesn't matter conservatives are not
sufficiently organized they don't have
sufficient institutional power
so ride it out you wait a week Bud Light
sales are going to increase again okay
you wait a week the conservatives are
upset that that the main conservative
host left at Fox is gone okay but
whatever in a week or two they'll come
back they haven't come back
they haven't something has changed here
two things have changed actually one the
the
political landscape has changed there is
a populist movement and there are
greater platforms for populists to speak
and there has been a flattening of of
the Public Square which the big Tech
life forms are doing their best to
counteract by censoring conservatives
but then you see chinks in the armor you
see a
an open-minded if not conservative at
least non-leftist like Elon Musk he buys
Twitter conservatives get to speak again
you see people cutting cords and pulling
out of traditional cable to begin with
you see conservatives recognizing that
the uniparty establishment doesn't serve
their interests either in its Republican
form or its Democrat form so you're
saying Alternatives pop up people like
Donald Trump taking over the Republican
Party even though Trump has no
particular Affinity or loyalty to the
Republican party and then the other side
of that is that the corporations even
the supposedly conservative ones
have become more liberal Fox made an
intentional choice to become more
liberal to fire its most prominent
conservative host to get rid of a lot of
other conservatives on the platform to
Blacklist conservatives from the
platform to to indulge in radical
leftist ideologies even in the very
language that they use and they they
just thought that they could get away
with it but there's just sometimes you
reach a bridge too far and
for it because we're still on YouTube
right now I'll speak uh Ambiguously
back in the 90s the social ideologies
and movements
they didn't push the conservatives too
far conservatives didn't like it but
they didn't push it too far in the 2000s
didn't totally push it too far even in
the early part of the 20 teens didn't
push you too far
but they reached a point on some of the
social stuff
where a flip just switched
or if a switch just flipped or a switch
switched I don't know and parents said
no more and Suburban voters said no more
and cable news viewers said no more and
beer drinkers said no more and the
corporations are waiting for that bounce
back I hope they don't hold their breath
now today is theology Thursday when I
have my friend Angela Uchi joining you
might remember Angela she came on
and described how she had previously
lived as a kind of new age hippie dippy
astrology Reiki practicing person and
and then got on the right track of
things
I've been feeling depressed since I was
13. that's
something's wrong I don't want to do
this anymore I'm just ready to die at
this point I'm bawling my eyes out I
just said out loud Jesus save me
and
something happened
the rest of the show continues now if
you have questions for Angela make sure
you put them into your chat right now
you do not want to miss it become a
member use code Noel skin WL he has to
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
good